the Germans are famously comfortable
with nudity they don't think it's a big
deal and they love nude beaches I was
very surprised to find that just outside
downtown Berlin near a canal there is a
nude beach I wanted to explore it
so it took along my guide Flula
don't worry when I called you and said
would you join me I didn't even say I
was going to a nude beach yeah dunno are
you making a lot cuz the Germans are
very comfortable with nudity we don't
enjoy clothing like if it's not required
like at a library or perhaps a
supermarket foodies are out cleavages
let those fly around like free birds
okay this is the first time I've been to
a nude beach how do you feel that's a
little strange I have to say you look
around and a lot of men walking and they
have their what are the Germans call it
penis did you mean is that always good
to learn any language I mean look you
turn right there and there's a man's ass
we're looking right into that man's ass
and it's just you know like have you not
seen that a man's anus before I mean I
have seen it yes there's another one
okay I love what you're wearing
who are we pointing the secret to great
thank you yeah to protect to protect and
then you have your trusty little fanny
pack up what do you have what do you
keep in there this next week you'll con
them give a snack - it's us schnitzel
that's up what is it it's going free you
just bought it I went to the nude beach
met a man and bit into his knit soul is
that what you say yeah because we just
did that
I had two meetings one host what do you
mean well could also be like a penis
you know there's new song analysis this
is no penis is not gluten-free the guy
back there he looks a lot like sting but
have statistics singles he's up for
Linden he probably comes here all the
time yeah yeah sending an SOS and the
massages in the Box message cuffing
hello how are you I'm good
what is your name would be this Tobias
would you like a snack
yeah sniffs oh there you go spits up its
up oh yeah this is normal very natural
in Germany right this is not normal for
me I am NOT happy when I'm nude your
bone without clothes yes actually I was
born with clothes
you